and now a message from the American  marijuana Growers Association  [Music]  hi I'm a farmer and I work hard every  day to grow high-quality marijuana the  biggest cash crop in these United States  I'd like to thank you for your support  of US Marijuana Policy because marijuana  is illegal I don't have to pay taxes  even better prohibition leads to  artificially inflated prices which means  a better quality of life for me and my  family as long as I don't get caught  just as importantly your tax dollars  support thousands of US agents who work  tirelessly to keep low-grade foreign  marijuana out of our country so thank  you America and remember whether your  nauseate from chemotherapy or just in  the mood for a nice cool buzz choose the  best pot in the world American homegrown  [Music]  you